this is Jocko podcast number 200 with
echo Charles and me
Jocko Willick good evening I come good
evening in the morning after my swim I
sit down and have a cup of coffee and
think Jim you're the luckiest guy in the
world and that is a quote from a man
named James sirs Lee a man who served
his country as a soldier in the US Army
so he volunteered for the army and then
volunteered to go fight in Vietnam a man
who made incredible sacrifices and who
faced incredible challenges challenges
that would overwhelm most people and yet
he carried on and he proved and is still
proving that the human will is stronger
than many of us ever realized and that
if you have the right attitude you can
look at a harrowing situation and still
call it lucky and it is an honor to have
this man with us tonight to talk about
his experiences and how he has overcome
so much adversity mr. James
serves Lee welcome to the show thank you
great to be here chuckle sir honor to
have you on and I apologize that the
fact that you had to travel all the way
out here from sunny Florida to sunny San
Diego but I'm honored that you were able
to make the trip I'm honored to be here
again thanks for asking and I like to
start at the beginning about you know
just where you came from where you grew
up and I
think we're talking about Minnesota
right we are you somehow you cover up
that accent pretty well well I've been
living in Florida since 1971 so I hope I
get rid of some of that so you grew up
what kind of was the family situation
growing up what your would your dad do
and whatnot my dad was a barber in
Rochester Minnesota and my mother for
the most part was a mother and a
housewife and worked a little bit a
part-time when I got into my teenage
years along with my older sister was
also a couple years older than me and
and what's Rochester Minnesota like but
Rochester Minnesota some in the Mayo
Clinic
so I mean it's probably that's the
biggest thing in town and IBM but it's
rural southeastern corner of Minnesota
just a great bunch of patriotic
Americans is what I was accustomed to
growing up and your dad served if I'm
correct your dad served in the Army Air
Corps he did was the radio operator on
b-17s and b-24s during World War two now
how much did he talk about that when you
were growing up you know not really a
whole lot I think the biggest thing that
I experienced with him was he had a a
footlocker that he brought back home and
I can remember probably as a nine or ten
year old kid trying to put on that stuff
and have the jacket drape all over me
and the pants too big and huge boots and
everything else but he never really said
too much about another than you know
where he experienced training in
different parts of the United States and
that type of thing and but but he was a
you said b-17 radio operator and be 24
and 20 hours so was he doing the
missions into Europe he did not do it
never left the United States okay
because when he when he finished
whatever training he had they made him a
trainer of other radio operators got it
so he was lucky well yeah otherwise is a
good chance you wouldn't even be here
exactly yeah those are the those are the
guys that were doing if you did 25
missions you got to go home but there
wasn't too many people that got to go
home
so
when you were growing up I mean going to
high school what was it your what was
your what were you into growing up
football basketball and bass and girls
and that's your which one was the
greatest priority and were you any good
I mean I was starting fullback on a
football team for three different you
know sophomore junior and senior year
and probably could have gone to college
but I wasn't exactly the greatest
student in the world so I did make
myself eligible to go on to college
you're focused on studying uh female
anatomy at this point yep that'd be a
good interpretation so so were you
planning to go to college were you
thinking about going to college where
your parents engin you towards college
my parents really never said too much
about that my older sister was already
two years into college at that point my
thing was if there would have been a
place where I could have gone to play
football but I didn't have to go to
school I'd have been the first one in
line for that location yeah and and as I
got closer to you know finish school and
in May of 1966 and as they got into
September of 66 I kind of thought about
and they said you know what I might do
is I might just join the military do
three years in the Army come back home
use the GI Bill and go to school
wherever I wanted to because I knew the
army would get me a GED just about as
quick as I got in there so that was kind
of some of my thoughts when I as they
got ready to join the military so so
what year were you set to graduate from
high school is that 1967
oh no 66 essentially six okay so May of
66 you started saying yourself alright
when I get done I'll just I'll just join
the join the army
well and I don't know if I even really
did that I mean it's it's probably been
more simple than that I don't know
whether I was a forward enough thinker
to actually be in that direction I
actually drove by the post office in
downtown Rochester Minnesota there's one
of those signs that were on a spring in
a hand uncle Sam red white and blue in
the big top hat and his finger was
pointed right at the wind
my car and it said Uncle Sam needs you
and I circled the block went in and
talked to the army recruiter not really
with any great intentions of joining but
just to kind of see what what that
process was all about and what maybe I
could do if I did join the army when
that recruiter saw you come through the
door he was thinking something
completely different
he said I got this guy well yeah they
were probably tremendously in need of
warm bodies at that point in time during
the Vietnam era later so this is 1966 so
how much were you aware of what was
going on in Vietnam at this time how
much were you watching the news how much
were you seeing as far as as far as the
Vietnam War goes because it had
definitely escalated by 1966 I mean I I
had a one of my friends who was who was
a pilot in Vietnam but he was in in the
Naval Academy and 1965 he they said they
didn't even talk about Vietnam in at the
Naval Academy at all it wasn't until
they got too close to the end of their
senior year that they started going oh
there's there's a war going on but by
1966 it had absolutely escalated and so
what were your thoughts were you
thinking hey this is if I go in then I
know what's gonna happen I know him to
be going to war I mean there was some
discussion with fellow classmates and
and I went to a parochial school and
there was a bigger public school that
was there in town and a lot of those
guys were talking about let's all go in
on the buddy system whether the Marine
Corps the army or something and I didn't
want to have anything to do with that I
mean that that was my answer to
everybody that ever raised that that
proposition but we were aware of what
was going on and probably she'd pass
through the living room your parents
would have the television on you'd see
it on the 6 o'clock or the 10 o'clock
news so you knew there was activity
going on but it wasn't like they didn't
scare me but it also wasn't attractant
to send me down to the army recruiter's
so after that first visit to the army
recruiter after you after Uncle Sam
called you out as you drove down the
street at what point so you go to see
him and
how much longer was it before you sign
the dotted line well I went home and
talked to my parents about it
mm and it's kind of one of those things
where I think they probably really
focused on the news much more than I
ever did and I mean the first thing that
I I mentioned about the possibility
during the army
my mother was in tears I'm sure because
of what you see on television my dad
having been former member the military
was not quite that way but just said hey
you know you know there's the Navy
there's the Air Force's a lot of
different possibilities why don't you
give that some thought and I just kind
of told them if I did join what I
thought I would want to do and that was
to be like a mechanic that was something
that I enjoy doing on my own with
vehicles and motorcycles that we had so
I mean I never thought about joining to
be a combat soldier and you know I
probably gave myself about two weeks had
a little bit more discussion with my
parents and that's probably when I
decided to go down and join again I was
18 years old so it wasn't it wasn't like
I needed permission to join I could have
done it on my own and that's basically
what I did so did you you were in the
cars then did you have your own car I
did did you have multiple cars at two
cars in a motorcycle and world were they
a 1957 Chevy in 1964 Chevy and Yamaha
250 motorcycle so you had you girls that
I mentioned you did a little bit yes and
and nothing about the Navy the Marine
Corps you did they did they give you a
contract in the army where you were
gonna become a mechanic did they do that
back then they did okay so you knew
right away hey you're gonna go in we're
gonna make you a mechanic and that
sounds like a pretty good plan right
especially because I'm just thinking
like when I joined the Navy all other
prospects in life didn't seem as cool as
that they didn't seem you know when you
said you wish there was a place where
you could just go and play football well
I wanted a place where I could just go
and play commando and there was a place
like that it was called the Navy and
that's how I ended up joining and it
seems like yeah I don't know I'm not
saying I didn't have any other options
but it just seemed like such a good
option for me it's so simple and
straightforward and that's actually one
of the things that I liked about the
Navy was when I joined nothing else
none of my previous life mattered it was
just here you go here's what you have to
do so
so did your did your mind shift at all
about your decision when you showed up
to boot camp no okay and and I think
really because you know when I reflect
on that now and look back that there was
a lot of guys who never left their
hometown never done anything when they
got drafted and I don't know what 40% of
the people in my basic training in it
were probably drafted didn't want to be
there and never had any intentions of
being in the military you know so scared
the living crap out of him I mean there
was people that cried half the night all
night in basic training you know
they were away from home for the first
time they weren't physical type of
people to start with and it was just
extremely difficult to watch a lot of
that while I went through basic training
Wow
so where did you go to basic training
Fort Polk Louisiana now where most of
the kids that you went through boot camp
with did they send them were they kids
that were from that area did you go to
boot camp like regionally or was it
people from all over the country people
from all over the country I think your
induction and where you go for basic
training in the Army at that time
depending on the timing of when you got
drafted or when you join could have been
to Fort Stewart Georgia think there were
places out here in California where they
actually had basic Fort Lewis Washington
had basic all over the place Fort Dix
New Jersey so you're in there with
people that have been drafted you said
40% I think roughly at that time and
there's I mean this is where people
start doing crazy things just to get out
of like you know wet their bed or
whatever sleepwalk and all this kind of
things so they just would get out of
their service did you see that kind of
thing
we had three guys that actually went
AWOL and stayed underneath one of those
elevated wood-frame World War two
barracks for three days
because even if theta got out from
underneath the barracks they wouldn't
have known how to get out of Louisiana
to get back where they were from
so people brought him food for three
days and then they finally decided to
surrender and that's the other the
interesting thing about so this is 1960
this is still 1966 and so the anti-war
movement wasn't in full swing yet was it
as far as just open hippies and the
streets and those kind of things that
wasn't really happening 66 was it no
more like 68 and 69 is when it really
got cranked up so these kids that were
coming in they were just horrified about
what was gonna happen and I don't know
whether it was even a fear of going to
Vietnam if it was just a fear of being
away from home the physicality of basic
training and people screaming and
hollering in your face and everything
else I mean I think that's what scared
are more than anything else you know
that that's one thing that they can
never put back in the bottle is these
days well first of all it's all
volunteer but second of all we've seen
when I joined the Navy I had seen you
know military boot camp movies since I
was born I mean we just knew every
little trick and it anticipated
everything that was gonna happen
and it seems like if you were a kid from
wherever and you got drafted and you'd
never left home and then you show up and
you got some drill sergeant going nuts
in your face yeah that's totally
different that's that's that's a that's
a that's a shock to the system and that
was before you could play that card I
guess that they use now you know there's
a timeout card in a lot of different
branches of the military where you can
go over and make a phone call and call
your Congressman if you want after being
mistreated you can call home and report
it well they used to say over there
we'll take you to the phone booth but
I'm not sure you'll ever make it back to
the unit so but you were you an athlete
you're a three-sport athlete you weren't
used to working and so it wasn't a big
deal for you to go
and you any volunteer to do it right so
you get done with boot camp and then
once an actually it must have to go some
kind of MLS school to learn your trade
right I stayed at Fort Polk Louisiana
for wheeled vehicle repair school and
that was another I think eight weeks or
seven weeks and then after that they
decided I was a pretty good mechanic so
they sent me to Fort Sill Oklahoma for
track vehicle repair school which was
everything that the army owned that had
a track on it you know self-propelled
howitzers and armored personnel carriers
tanks you name it anything that had it
had a track on it
did you enjoy all that I did yeah like I
have a nephew that he's just loves all
kinds of mission big machinery you know
he just anything that any caterpillar
any big piece of machinery he just loves
it and I could see him joining the army
to be a tank repairman and then so how
long is that school last another eight
weeks and at this point are you I mean
with the war going on are you starting
to be more aware of possibilities of
where you could end up well you would
hear people talking about it and some of
the people that I took the track vehicle
school with were people that have been
in the military for a year year and a
half two years Robert ee5 for some of
them that's even he six who had had the
wheel part of it but never at the track
part and I think they were kind of
merging those two MLS's
so that's why they were training in both
both categories did you have any guys in
those schools that had already been to
Vietnam we did not not in either one of
those schools but I did my first
assignment was to the 24th Infantry
Division in Germany and there were
Vietnam veterans and our unit in Germany
so you wrap up your school and that's
your first your first permanent duty is
over in Germany and you show up there
which has got to be a good time I think
19 necessarily in a 67 yet yep we're in
67 so 1967 how old are you 19 19 years
old and you get stationed where in
Germany Oscar
did you did you drink any beer while you
were there a little bit yeah I think
everything right outside the hey just
like the military bases here in this
country all the pubs are right outside
the gate and you're 19 years old
you got more you're the richest human
being in the world because you got that
whatever you do III or not $97 a month
is what it paid for that you're in the
air me I quit a hundred and fifty dollar
a week job to get ninety seven dollars a
month but I got all the clothes and free
food I wouldn't say yeah I was looking
at one of my pay stubs the other day for
when I first joined the Navy and it was
I want to say it was like 700 bucks a
month or six hundred and forty two
dollars a month and I was looking at it
going dang they relieved they got me
pretty good for a month but you're in
Germany and and what's your job there I
mean you're you're you're working on
tracks like you were supposed to hear
that's what you're doing well I did I
did a little bit of that and what the
assignment to do was run the ti bate
technical inspection on all the vehicles
you know you know having been around the
military every vehicle has to have a
logbook all the logbooks have to be
up-to-date with repairs and maintenance
on them so my job was to sort of ferret
out what needed to be done making sure
the driver took care of it and if not
then we sent the rest over with a work
order over to the regular mechanics and
they replaced or fix something that was
damaged at that point now are you doing
any time in the field at this point we
used to go to grab and beer Hohenfels
while flicking and do do training out
out that way so you'd go out and do a
big exercise and when you do those
exercises would you be would you would
you would you be up one of the crew on
any tracks or would you be standing by
to repair them only standing by to
repair because the motor pool was
battalion motor pool and it was big
enough that you were you know you had
the full contingent of mechanics welders
and everything else and and then how
long did you spend in Germany I spent
about eight months in Germany before a
volunteer to go to Vietnam now at this
point you said you did have guys that
had been
in Vietnam and they were with you and
what were they what was the feedback
they were giving you well I mean they
weren't negative about it they weren't
trying to make it overly scary I think
they were realistic and honest about it
but I think one of the things that when
I look back at that now they were okay
and they were alive so you know maybe
it's really not that bad yeah but I mean
if it been somebody that had been
seriously injured right maybe he'd be
going maybe I need to think about this a
little bit more yeah I mean I was kind
of determined to go and the reason that
I was because I felt like when I was in
Germany I felt like I had a civilian job
with a green uniform I didn't figure I
was being utilized or I was using myself
to the best of my ability I I joined
because I wanted to make some kind of a
contribution but you know wasn't a John
Wayne kind of story or anything that big
but I just didn't feel like I was
accomplishing that there and the First
Sergeant talked to me about it and said
you know you need to think about this
I'm gonna give you three or four days
talk to some of the guys that have been
in Vietnam because I mean I think he'd
been and it wasn't anything he just
wanted to rubber-stamp and put you on a
plane and send you back and get you
ready to go he was really a genuine kind
of person who felt like hey make sure
this is what you want before we actually
sign the paperwork and send yawn yeah
there's there's also different people
have different experiences in war and I
know in Iraq there is places in Iraq
where the living conditions were better
than most than much of the living
conditions that I experienced in my
normal life in America and then you go
ten miles away or sometimes even three
miles from that point and you're outside
at some Forward Operating Base and it's
really dangerous and really hard living
conditions and it just depends on where
you are and I think the other thing you
were just talking about I think they
call it survivor's bias which is the
only people that we get to talk to like
it happens with businesses you know
someone says oh I did this with my
business and and that's why I'm a
multimillionaire now and says everyone
says well that must have worked so I'll
what you don't get to talk to as all the
people that they tried that and it
failed so yeah from your perspective
you're hearing from guys that were in
Vietnam and like you said they I don't
wanna say they had a good time but it
wasn't that bad
because they were coming back to be able
to tell you about it so you you thought
about it for a few days what were you
seeing on the news at this point you
didn't see much news at all when I was
in Germany I mean I don't know whether I
ever watched a television all the while
I was there and were there were there
any like Intel reports where their
casualty reports were you seeing
I got remember for me in Iraq I was
always paying attention to how many well
how many people were getting killed
every month I mean I I tracked that all
time and you know you'd see those
numbers creeping up and they crept up
and it crept up and I paid attention
that was that something that you were
looking at thinking well hey that could
be me never saw any or never heard any
reports of that at all I mean I think
there were there was information shared
that people were dying in Vietnam but
there wasn't any statistical paperwork
that actually would bear out the all
those numbers so you you talked to the
First Sergeant he tells you give it a
few days you give it a few days and you
and you say you know I'm still in I want
to go do this did you when you go
volunteer what do they do
are they assigning you to a specific
unit I think just shipping you off to
Vietnam and you're gonna sign when you
get there that's what happens your
replacement troop scene basically I
think when when Vietnam first got
started whole units went to Vietnam but
as time went on everybody became a
replacement troop somebody would rotate
out tomorrow another guy would come in
three days later another guide rotate a
month you know what I mean
I just went on that way all the while I
was in country so how long did they give
you to prepare did you anything
different to prepare you just how long
did it take from the time you said hey I
want to go yep and then how long was it
before he left um it was about two weeks
before actually got orders that came
down from battalion or Brigade went home
on a thirty
leave back to Minnesota during the month
of February of 1968 and then I reported
to Fort Lewis Washington on the the last
couple days of February 68 was in
country by March the first 68g flyover
on civilian aircraft I did with
stewardesses and threat of airlines if I
remember correctly which is not even in
existence anymore and what was it called
Braniff Braniff Airlines and that was
what about saying goodbye to your
parents where was your dad nervous was
your mom a disaster since she was
already sad when you joined the Army in
the first place it was pretty hard on my
mom and I mean I think it was difficult
for my dad too because I'm sure they
probably both thought I was just
absolutely crazy for volunteering to go
I mean I could have stayed in Germany
ran out my three years and got out of
the military but I just couldn't see
myself doing that so was it was
difficult for so civilian flight you get
over there well you know again talking
about movies and we all see the movies
and you know I watched all those Vietnam
War movies growing up and you they
always have the iconic scenes of the new
guys in their fresh camouflage uniforms
getting off the bird and there's the the
hardened veterans that are heading home
after a year of combat and and they look
like they've been through a year of
combat did you did you see that I did
yeah they were actually loading planes
on the same location that we were
offloading so just exactly like you
described as what took place any anybody
talked to you about anything anybody say
anything to you um I mean usually
they're kind of giving you just a
thumbs-up and their great big smile on
their face because they know their load
loading the bird and going home so
they're happy to be getting out of there
and the attitude with the guys that you
were with you know you already talked
about the draftees in boot camp that are
freaking out was there any guys now that
are heading to Vietnam and there and
some of those guys probably just got out
of advanced infantry training or
whatever the the
and have been in the Army for whatever
four months
yeah four months and then maybe a 30-day
leave at home and on their way to
Vietnam and again that same kind of
situation and I think there whether you
join the army or you got drafted I think
there's still that fear even though
that's what you signed up for if you
enlisted there's that fear of the
unknown that you've gotten off this
plane and what's going to happen next
it's weird because there's the I think
that a lot of this your attitude goes a
long way because there's definitely
people and times and myself included
where I would think there's nothing's
gonna happen to me like it'll happen to
anyone else I've talked about this
before like I always feel if I'm on a
commercial airline and it blows up in
the sky that I'm gonna live like I'm
gonna grab the seat cushion or something
I'm gonna figure it out so there's that
kind of stupid ignorance that that I
know I had especially when I was younger
like nothing was ever gonna happen to me
and I I would see that in my guys you
know when I was old I didn't go to war
until I was you know older and I saw
some of the guys that you could tell
they didn't they didn't think anything
was gonna happen to him and I had other
guys where you would swear in their mind
they had a target on the back of their
head every step that they took and so
he'd get a drastic difference between
people's attitudes did you see that
between did you see that with different
guys and what did you think yourself I
did see that same thing I don't think
that's changed any from Vietnam to the
generation that served in Iraq or
Afghanistan I think that mixture and
that percentage is probably still the
same all the time certainly a lot of
people who had a certain mos but maybe
they had some other kind of a job in the
States would say well I might be 11
Bravo which is a grunt but I'm not going
to have to do that because I was the
company Armour and I'll be I'll be
running you know distributing weapons
and stuff like that but you'd see them
out in the field sometime later they'd
be humping the bush with the 65 pound
pack
they're back so I mean I think there was
a certain fear but a certain courage as
well to that I think most of the people
that I ever served with displayed and I
think even the guys that got drafted
came to the resolve that you know look
at I'm here I might as well make the
best of this there's no sense in
complaining or whining and let's just go
ahead and get our year-end get my two
years in in the military and get it over
with and I can go home so I mean I've
always said that the people that I
served with were tremendously courageous
and extremely brave individuals I never
saw anything that I would ever be afraid
to serve alongside of that person so
yeah that's powerful that's the American
that's the American servicemen right
there because he even when I was talking
about guys that I knew that would I had
friends that would verbally you know
they'd say oh I'm not feeling good about
tonight man maybe they would say that
stuff yep
and guess what they get on their gear
and they go out night after night and I
actually have to give them more credit
because sometimes I think well I'm not I
think I'm gonna be fine but it doesn't
take me that much courage to overcome
that and here's a guy that has that
feeling night after night but like you
said every time night after night
they're getting their gear on they're
going out and doing their job how did
you get assigned so now you show up this
is just this is like this is what the
Army has the reputation of the big army
hey you're a piece you're a piece you're
you're a cog in the machine you give
them your I mean how did that process
work well you get to Vietnam you do a
three-day in-country orientation where
they teach you all about snakes and
bamboo Vipers and all that crazy stuff
and what not to do and punji stakes and
all that and then I'm sure that while
you're there they're working on who
needs a track vehicle mechanic or who
needs infantryman whichever the case may
be and they just put me on a plane and
flew me up to deny or actually do me
that you lie on that one and then hell
copter meat LZ Baldy out in the middle
of nowhere and that's how I got to the
unit I served with now as you're getting
further and further away from
civilization did the hair on the
backyard axe start to stand up
straighter well I'm probably a little
bit on the crazy side and I think the
curiosity factor I was okay with you
know I mean I'm like you're like you're
talking about I've never felt like I'm
not gonna say I've never felt fear but
I've always just been excited about
what's gonna happen next I never worried
when I was in country about dying that
thought never crossed my mind I just
felt like if I did what I knew to do and
use the the experiences that I had and
everything else and applied them the way
you're supposed to I was going to be
okay so you roll it into LZ Baldy we're
at where abouts in Vietnam was that
that's in the I Corps area closer up to
the DMZ was about 17 kilometers
southwest of Danang and so is it it's
pretty remote location then called the
quays on valleys our area of operation
and mean a lot of Vietcong lotta NVA in
that area especially in 68 and 69 and
how big how big was that was the Forward
Operating Base that you were staying at
how big was it
mm not very big I mean battalion
headquarters oh and and then um so you
check in there you land on your airplane
you land on the helicopter get out of
the helicopter and then what happens
well I I go to F troops company
headquarters report to the First
Sergeant tell him who I am and what I am
and the first sergeant called everybody
son so he said son I told him I was a UH
track vehicle mechanic and feet point me
in the direction the motor pool I'd go
report to the motor sergeant he said son
we really don't have a motor pool here
in Vietnam he said there is a guy that
runs the maintenance department he spec
five so-and-so and he said you can
you'll see him at Chow tonight but
she'll be a machine gunner on a 1-1 3-8
one and we'll make sure you get a
toolbox so if anything goes wrong
while you're out there that's your job
to fix them so there's the wake-up call
the you know I fought in the Battle of
Ramadi in 2006 and you know what vehicle
we use for casualty evacuation a113
yep the exact same vehicle so that's
where you got a sign you got a sign to
a113 which is a normal armored personnel
carrier carrier made out of aluminum if
I'm correct I'm not sure probably
wouldn't be a bit surprised and they're
very they're like a babe they're
basically a box with tracks that's
basically what they look like there's a
box with tracks on them they're not huge
they're not as big as a tank how many
people you think they hold maybe you
could probably put eight or ten on the
inside yeah we used to are joke about
armored personnel carriers was how many
people can you fit into him one more
suit so that's what you get assigned so
now you realize okay there's no motor
pool here there's no that's not
happening
he says you're gonna be a machine gunner
on one of these one one threes so you
check in who you checking in with now
are you well when when my unit my
platoon was out in the field and they
came back in for child that night that's
when I was introduced to the Lt and the
and the platoon sergeant and then I
don't know they just picked a track that
was short one guy and that's the one I
went to and how many how many tracks do
you have in your platoon nine wow that's
a pretty big balloon well it's 18 m60
machine guns 9 50 caliber and 1 106
recoilless rifle so it's it's a lot of
fire man that's that's that's serious
business I didn't think they had that
many in one platoon and so then ok so
now you settle in it and and what kind
of what kind of missions were you guys
doing well when I originally got in
country they called him Search and
Destroy and then I think somebody in
Washington decided we need to change it
to search and clear it didn't sound
quite as disastrous if he called it
search and clear but the mission was
exactly the same thing he still went out
checked all the villages checked all the
people any
the result working in the fields looking
for caches of rice looking for weapons
that were hidden in different villages
and that type of thing sometimes you'd
have intelligence reports that would
send you somewhere where maybe they had
some information that there was
something bad going on sometimes it was
there sometimes it wasn't the area of
operation that I actually worked in was
exactly the same one meal I was in my my
area of operation we called it the pink
Ville on our map and I think lieutenant
Kali's thing had happened three weeks or
four weeks after I got in country or
something like in third week in March or
maybe around the 1st of April you know
you know you're familiar with yeah and
then but you guys did you guys hear
anything about it I think we heard a
little bit about it but communication
back then was not the same as it is
today I mean obviously nobody had
cellphones or anything like that you
didn't have pictures or any information
we just knew there was a lot of people
in that village and it was I mean it was
a sizable village for as remote as it
was most of them were just all rice
farmers that were out there so they did
was harvest rice and carry it to market
but we'd been through there a number of
different times before and after the
actual meal I massacre and III think the
thing that was interesting about Vietnam
was for villagers if I used an
interpreter to ask somebody a question
in the village about what they'd rather
have the NVA in charge of where they'd
rather have the Americans or the South
Vietnamese military in charge and they
were really always reluctant to answer
that question because I don't think
there was a good answer they could give
me you know if they answered that one
way it kind of meant they were
Vietnamese NVA sympathizers and if they
answered it the other way then that
meant they were totally opposed and they
would support us but we know that wasn't
the way it happened either they were
just trying to grow rice and stay alive
so I mean if we would leave him alone
and the NBA would leave him alone they'd
be the happiest people on the face of
the earth but it
didn't happen that way we didn't abused
them but the NVA abused him all the time
not only further rice but you know for
shelter and everything else how what was
your op tempo like and so so how long
would you go out on a mission for I mean
probably the standard time is about 20
to 22 days at a time and then we get
resupplied in the field with with
Chinooks
for fuel and for water and food and
everything so that this Forward
Operating Base that you were out that
that you were out of when that platoon
came back they'd been out for a long
time they'd been out for and I own that
particular one I don't know but I would
have to guess they probably were at
least a two-week period of time when she
went out and you started through the
area of operation usually didn't come
back until you cover the whole thing and
but you guys are living do you have DF
dismounts with you or is everyone on is
everyone in the platoon traveling inside
the track and sleeping inside the track
and you got water
I mean what's like the daily routine
like well you get up and fix breakfast
you know fix them coffee or some sea
rations and you know easy to carry it
because your armored personnel carriers
wait didn't make a lot of difference to
us we'd have somebody would fix this
somebody would fix the coffee we'd all
kind of share the meal together because
you didn't have any food that came out
to the field very often and we just sit
down maybe the night before that morning
with the Lt and go over what the daily
operation was and follow up with a Mylar
cover on the map sheet and a grease
pencil and you know go through the
checkpoints throughout the course of the
day you know if you faced any any
difficulties you you know just faced it
head-on return fire called in artillery
maybe you'd get a call an infantry unit
to be pinned down nice burn about being
armored personnel carriers you could
move real fast lay down a lot of
suppressing fire and let them back out
and save them we did that for Marines as
well as United States Army so then and
then this is just what you do this is
just the
day in day out all day every day and
your during the nighttime you see you
stay you know you stay on watch but
you're in a perimeter somehow and you
circle up just like wagon trains in an
old western television program yeah like
John Wayne and the guys and and then
everybody would stay up on the track
there'd be two hour segments from 10:00
to midnight on down to six o'clock in
the morning you'd rotate every two hours
and you just be you know you'd have
claymores out and set up your perimeter
defense and everything you'd call in
debt cons so that you had positions
available for local or Tillery could
drop stuff real quick if you needed to
have it now it seems like it would not
be a great move for the Vietcong or for
the NVA to attack you know this you guys
I mean how often did they attack never
well I was there but I think the the big
thing is is that one of the things you
have going for you is you have the speed
of movement that you could travel with
an armored personnel carrier so there
really wasn't any way that they could
pattern you and go set up in front of
you or follow you fast enough to be even
if they probably walked through the
night to get you which might have been
possible but it never happened I just
don't think they ever tried to do that
when they had enough infantry units and
Marines that were in the area and they
were walking slower and their movement
was slower that's who they would set up
on and then you guys would utilize your
firepower to go help out if some
infantry unit called for help you guys
would roll in and and lay down the
Thunder which you guys most certainly
had that weapons packages know is no
joke right there Wow Wow
but when you talked about it before when
we've rode two machine gunners the hatch
was always open on an APC and two
machine gunners sat on the back on that
hatch with the guns out to the right and
left of course the the turret was in the
center with the 50 caliber and you never
got down inside I mean it only if maybe
if you were taking fire you'd get down
and
behind the m60 but you stayed up on top
all the time because I guess if you were
ever going to hit a landmine which is
you know something that happened quite
often you didn't want to be down inside
but stuff exploding from from that
explosion you wanted to be on the top
and maybe get blown clear of it so that
was out was that the biggest threat to
the tracks was getting hit in some kind
of landmine or an RPG rocket from a
woodland the
yeah I mean obviously in Iraq and
Afghanistan really I mean I can really
only talk about Iraq from my experience
but yeah the obviously the roadside
bombs were what they what they did that
was what they did and they did it well
and you know the the bigger vehicles
that we got the bigger bombs they built
and so when it started my first
deployment we were in Humvees with we
didn't have we literally didn't have
doors on our Humvees we actually turned
the seats to face outboard so that we
could present our weapon and that we
could present our front plate of our of
our body armor and then eventually we
put we weld the doors together and put
steel doors on and then by the time I
got back to Iraq we had armored Humvees
and then after that came the big giant
mine-resistant vehicles and the whole
time the enemy just kept building bigger
and bigger and bigger bombs but we were
always we were oftentimes not always but
we were oftentimes channelized on roads
because of bridges are because of
because of just being in the city
whereas you guys did you guys you guys
with tracks in the jungle or you know
you guys could just go wherever you want
to do is that right
pretty much so the biggest thing that we
had to do and I mean that was the number
one thing and part of the training with
you drove her you were commanding a
track was you never take the same stream
crossing twice you you tracked the
vehicle right directly in front of you
you never get outside of the lead tracks
tracks in the ground and we'd stay in
the paddies or around the paddies as
much as possible because they weren't
very likely to to put a landmine in the
rice paddies it would be on the road or
the edge of the road or maybe on a rice
paddy
but we never never went in that
direction very often either and what was
your what was your leadership like you
know your your young lieutenant platoon
commander what was he like what was your
platoon sergeant like what did what was
your interaction with those guys like
and even your vehicle so who was in
charge of of your track was he was a
young five probably 21 or 22 years old
at that time and the leadership in my
platoon the platoon leader was a was a
great person lieutenant and I mean it
was one of those things that I learned
very early on the best thing that I
could do for the first three or four
months was just shut up and listen and
watch what was going on and followed the
lead of the people that really knew what
was going on the platoon sergeant was
that same kind of a person you know the
difference when the platoon sergeant was
that he was probably in his 30s he was
married he had children back home so I
don't think it was as easy for him to be
a strong leader and a strong
decision-maker because I think that was
on his mind a lot the LT was not that
way in everybody that we served with was
not that way I don't know if I know
anybody else that I served with for ten
and a half months that was married other
than most of the platoon sergeants or
the first surgeon so they have that in
the back of their mind they're thinking
about you can sense that they're maybe
leaning a little bit towards trying to
stay alive and trying to take less risk
and you you know to all that works is
that's not always the best person to
have for a leader if you're not tuned in
24/7 while you're there you're in
trouble you know that's the only way to
survive you have to be conscious of
every fly that lands on on your food you
know what I mean you just you just got
that heightened sense of awareness that
it's probably lucky you can even go to
sleep when you lay down at night because
you're the adrenaline is pumps so much
all day long for you
yeah something else that I always felt
and I don't know if I'm right or wrong
but I always felt that if you were
thinking about other things like family
that was gonna make you less aggressive
and as far as I can tell if your
aggression if you're not aggressive on
the battlefield that has a higher
probability of getting you killed then
if you're aggressive I think that
hesitation is a bad thing and I look I'm
not saying and I used to try and make
this clear all the time I'm not talking
about you know being hyper aggressive
and running to your death that's not
what I'm talking about but if there's
something going on and you're nervous
about making a move that's not a good
thing to have happening and it would
make when I would have guys that I could
see were thinking about other things it
would make me nervous that they were
going to hesitate when they needed to
move or needed to make something happen
I agree a hundred percent because we
experienced a lot of that and the only
thing I would do when I got to a
position where I was an e5 or eventually
became an e6 was to identify those
people and try to utilize them in some
spot where they weren't going to get
anybody else killed that wasn't always
real easy to do short of actually
sending him back to the rear area and
not let him come out in out in the field
with us but if you were Shore to people
you didn't have that option very often
either so you you and efj were you an e4
when you got in country I was and then
you got promoted to e5 right did that
change your position in in the track at
all it took me off the machine gun and
put me behind the 50 that's good
did you uh and then did you eventually
make east six I did and did that change
your position again at some point did
you become like the vehicle commander I
became what was called the field first
sergeant what they called six alpha and
in the army I was on the command track
out in the field with with the company
commander and then two other machine
gunners on our track so you did you
leave your platoon to go and
with the company commander I did and
what's your what's your job when you're
in that position well basically
everything you do for the daily
operation you're kind of in charge of or
overseeing everything you're you know
because keep in mind now we've got not
just my third Platoon out there but the
second and the first might be with us or
they might be off on an operation of
their own sometimes two platoons that go
out together and we want to go a
different direction so you had to be
cognizant of where everybody was all the
time and what they were doing any
difficulties that they were having and
it was a brand-new company commander who
did not have any Vietnam experience so
that it was almost like having to train
the CEO once he got there so I think the
fact that I got assigned to that track
was what the first sergeant felt enough
confidence in me that I could do that
and not be a jerk to him or not worry
about him being a captain versus me
being an e6 I mean that part never
bothered me anyway you know men never
paid much attention to that how long had
you been in Vietnam when you got moved
to that assignment I had been in country
about eight and a half months so that
was that's like perfect then you got a
you know you're experienced and the
company commander didn't have any
experience I know I always had a I had a
special vehicle we in a Humvee the
vehicle commanders sits in the in
basically the front right passenger seat
and you know you're the one that's
supposed to be kind of directing the
vehicle and and I would always have to
do other things because I was either in
a salt force command or ground force
command or whatever so I always had I
always took the best smartest driver so
that I didn't have to do worry about him
you know and it's kind of the same
relationship you know he knew that hey
he needed to handle all the stuff going
on with the vehicle but that's um that's
like the way the military does things
the military does things like that right
there where they take the the new
company commander that doesn't have any
experience and they give them a guy that
can help advise him in in a positive way
to make sure he doesn't for lack of a
better word screw anything up yeah I
thought it was a very enjoyable process
because I mean I didn't intend to be a
career soldier so I mean I just knew
that I had X number of time amount of
time days months whatever it was but I
just always felt like if I'm gonna do
something I'm gonna do it to the best of
my ability I'm sure I didn't have all
the answers but I also knew who to talk
to who had still been around even longer
than I had some guys who had extended
been there 14 15 months already you know
and had a great deal more experience
than I did I would ask I'm not afraid to
get information from somebody I mean
that's that's that knowledge could save
a lot of people's lives in that that's a
big part of what I felt like I was
responsible for now I'm responsible for
the whole company which is you know I
don't know 210 people I guess at that
point now you mentioned that the the the
enemy was not outright openly attacking
you but you guys were responding what
was the casualty rate for f-troop while
you were there I mean just in terms of
how often were you guys taking
casualties and I know I looked there's a
really good website that you guys have
from F Troop in Vietnam and it in where
the numbers written down in 1967 so
before you showed up there was there was
four people from from F Troop that were
killed in action in 1968 so the year
that you were there that number went up
five times these were and according to
that document it said that there was 20
20 men killed in action in in 1968 so
that is some heavy contact I mean that's
more than ten percent that more than 10
percent that's not that's not counting
wounded
action that's all killed in action so
even though you said the enemy wasn't
attacking you very often you guys must
have been in some significant enemy
contacts to be taking those those kind
of casualties well and I think most of
those that I'm familiar with were all
land mines and they were land mines for
people on the vehicles where it blew the
m11 one three two pieces I mean the the
reason we had a new company commander in
the fall of 68 was because the company
commander had directed a new driver to
do a stream crossing that we knew you
shouldn't cross a second or third time
and it blew they hit a 500 pounder and I
mean it just killed all four people on
the track and it blew the captain off he
was riding on the drivers hatch that was
open blew him clear but injured him
seriously that's why we ended up with a
new company commander and then Jim
Starkey was from San Jose California was
a real good friend of mine was killed in
April of 1968 shortly after you know
like six weeks after I got in country
but he was just one of those guys that
love girls and played sports so we
immediately became a great friend that's
one of the one of the horrible things
about the 1-1 3 and it's really the same
thing with a Humvee they built those
things to have a low profile because
when you're talking about tank battles
what you want to have is you want to
have a low profile so that you can hide
behind you can take the vehicle and you
can you can sink it into a depression
you can get behind some kind of a
terrain feature and not get shot at the
problem with designing vehicles with an
extremely low profile is that they have
no ground clearance and so when there's
a landmine underneath them it just it
just distracts those vehicles and that's
why the the new vehicles the
mine-resistant vehicles they're super
tall off the ground they have these big
v-shaped holes that literally deflects
some of the power of the bombs that the
data and the enemy plants so that's one
of the problems with these 1 1 3 s is
there's not much ground
clearance on them and so when they get
hit with a with a a mine it does
catastrophic damage often and so that
was what you you guys that was the major
threat from the enemy was was hitting
these these bombs yeah and I would have
to guess I mean I had never heard that
number before that we lost one in 1968
but I would have to guess it maybe two
or three of those might have been small
arms fire and the rest were all from
their vehicles being blown up how did
that grate on your nerves the the
landmine explosions yeah well again you
you still just do everything to the best
of your ability you have to track that
vehicle in front of it now obviously if
you're the lead track and that changes
periodically but you know you're in
greater jeopardy that you could hit
something because there's no way in the
world that you can you can't can't go
out and do you know mine detectors and
stuff you're you're out in the middle of
nowhere you probably get shot off the
track trying to run detectors and you
would just run and through it but in
most of ours were not that kind of
explosion they were more bad choices by
people who thought this time it's gonna
be okay
and you just can't do things that way
it's never gonna be okay it's always
going to be bad and if you think that
direction you'll usually be safe ninety
percent of the time and and like I said
when like when the captain made that
decision my best friend from walk sad
sheet Texas Chris Wendler was his driver
and Chris would have never crossed that
stream as his driver but he had a
replacement because Chris was back home
in Texas on a 30-day extension leave and
I mean I've asked Chris that question
over all the years you know would you
have crossed it he said but captain
Davis probably would have listened to me
but he probably wouldn't listen to
anybody else because Chris had a great
deal of experience Drive important
that's one of the misconceptions about
the military and it's really one of the
Mexican
exceptions about leadership is is the
last thing that I want as a leader is to
have a bunch of yes men that are just
gonna do what I tell them to do because
I told them to do it
I want people that are going to say hey
Jacque I don't know if that's the best
idea or hey that we should do this a
different way and and people don't think
that that's gonna happen in the military
that's what you want you want that kind
of environment inside the military and
the good thing is that way when I would
make a call and guys would execute I
knew it was a good call cuz no one gave
me any pushback because believe me I had
a relationship with my guys if I was
saying telling them to do something
stupid they'd say hey boss
we needed we need to put go-go on hold
right now and and figure this out
there's got to be a better way so that's
the way that that's how I that's how I
make good decisions not because I'm
great it's cuz I got a bunch of great
guys working for me that are gonna tell
me hey that's not the right call and
that's a classic example right there you
know if if Chris who had the experience
and had the bill the the wherewithal to
say hey boss we don't want to cross
right there it's not a good call let's
just go ten meters down mix it up a
little bit that's the kind of thing
where that that won't save lives and the
other thing that you just talked on this
is another thing that people get really
surprised about is even because we work
I work with a lot of companies and
businesses and people say well you know
my guys get complacent get complacent
with things because you know there's
there's it's not combat so people get
complacent and I always have to explain
people get complacent in combat - you go
on you go on your 14th patrol on a row
in a row and nothing's happened for the
last 13 patrols and you think oh you
know we can we can cross here or we
don't need to we need to pack extra ammo
or I don't need to carry that extra
radio battery because I haven't needed
it yet and when you cut those corners
when you get complacent that's when
these horrible things happen you cannot
get complacent and all those all those
servicemen out there right now
servicemen and women don't cut corners
don't do it you got to hold the line and
if you see people cutting corners call
them
one of the biggest things that some of
the infantry units used to do was get
complacent and not put claymores out
when they set up for the night and just
like you mentioned it might have worked
12 or 13 times before but the one time
you decide you're going to leave it in
your pack that's exactly when Charlie
decides to come through the perimeter
not that he knew but you were prepared
yeah that's that's the guaranteed way to
get attacked don't set up claymores
every time you set up claymores and
you're prepared and everyone standing
watch correctly that's how you don't get
attacked
the minute that someone slacks off yeah
that's that's what that's what since you
go in sideways now you mentioned that
draftees that pretty much when you were
there once you guys were in country once
you were doing your job did you could
you even tell the difference between who
was a draftee and who wasn't only a few
but I asked him if that was the case
because there was no other
identification to anybody but you know
again I say this because in 10 and a
half months period of time they were
still the most courageous and brave
people that I've ever served with I
think they've resolved all that draft
stuff and I don't want to be here before
they got in country or right after they
got in country because they were they
were not complacent at all once once I
started to work with them yeah I had a
retired general who is who was one of
david hackworth company commanders in
vietnam and i asked him about the
draftees and he said he couldn't tell
who was a draft Dean who wasn't and and
I always you know I hear a lot of people
ask me about the Ennis getting into the
business world people ask me about what
it's like to or you know how do you
handle these Millennials and I always
bring up people like Hackworth who says
who Hackworth said he loved his draftees
I mean I don't think you can get a
harder workforce to deal with than
someone that was drafted to Vietnam that
doesn't believe in the war that doesn't
want to be there and who can lose their
life doing this job ok I get it the
Millennial might like looking at his
phone or whatever but that still is a
completely different deal but if you
have good leadership and you explain to
them why it's important
and you get them involved and give them
ownership they'll step up and and you're
the your another example of someone
looking at me and saying hey the
draftees if they knew what was going on
we couldn't tell who is who and that's
again a testament not only to good
leadership but it's a testament to two
American soldier and absolutely what and
what we do here when you you you said
you got shifted into that new job with a
company commander at eight and a half
months at our you start you know and we
said this a little bit not as much as
you guys not as much as I hear about it
in Vietnam but we might have had this
creep into our head a little bit of the
idea of you know you've got short time
and it's almost time to go home and and
did that start creeping into your mind
at all at eight and a half months there
was that too far away where you're not
even thinking about it yet I honestly
never gave it any thought at all I mean
I knew what my rotation date was but a
lot of guys actually made what was
called a short time calendar that's a
bad idea - never never did that at all
so you just every day was a new day
you're gonna do your best job and if
you're doing what you're doing that's
the best you can do and and that's one
more thing I wanted to say this cuz
again we got young folks in the military
out there when I was talking about hey
some people are afraid some people
aren't afraid some people think it's
gonna happen them some people think
it'll never happen them look wherever
you are on that spectrum what I can say
is this there's things that you can
control there's things that you can't
control and as you're going into combat
before you go into combat train hard be
prepared know your weapon systems know
your immediate action drills then that's
that's the best you can do you've done
everything you can to take control over
what you can control once you're in
combat there's some things that you're
not gonna be able to control and if you
worry about those things it's actually a
set it actually negatively impacts you
if you're worried about things that you
can't control if you're worried about
what's going on at home if you're
worried about may although
things that gonna take away your
aggressiveness takes will take away your
awareness take away your attention those
things are gonna drag you in the wrong
direction
so don't worry about the things that you
can't control it's okay to be afraid to
like hey if you're if you're scared
guess what it's normal you're going into
a hard situation it's normal you're
gonna be you're gonna feel that you're
gonna feel your guts gonna feel up what
do they say butterflies in your stomach
that's normal it's okay it's no big deal
that's what people feel it's you don't
need to think you're you're weak because
you're feeling that you're just going
into survival mode you got butterflies
in your stomach because your Bloods
drawn away from there because you want
to focus on other things it's a positive
thing so don't worry about those things
you can't control focus on what you
can't control
and if you're if you feeling a little
bit afraid good that means your your
mind is in the right place you're aware
and you're in a hyper sensory mode so
you can survive out on the battlefield
that's what's going on what was the MIT
what was going on with the mission where
you got wounded we'd been out on a
search and clear for that whole day I
mean probably had been out in the field
for six or seven days at that point I
had picked the night logger position we
set up that evening about 5:30 or 6
o'clock we were supposed to get resupply
and get get hot child that night brought
up by helicopter and so what I was doing
was once the platoons got set up on the
perimeter and our command track was in
the center of the circle I went out to
check the claymores and all the
perimeter defense to make sure that
everybody put out what I mean because I
just did that before I don't know
whether that was my responsibility as in
my new position but I probably slept
much better knowing that I had checked
it and that's when I stepped on a
landmine and was checking the perimeter
and we what do you remember about
stepping on a landmine I don't remember
it blowing I remember going up in the
air and I remember coming back down
I never lost consciousness you know from
the from the explosion but when I laid
on my back and the medic came over and
I'd known the medic for seven or eight
months and and tears were running it
running down his face and he was telling
me I was going to be okay I knew it
wasn't real good not what you want to
hear from the medic honored at what
point so that was so then what happens
your well I mean I'd laid there for a
little bit while he's trying to do stuff
the interesting thing that happened with
my my explosion was all powder there was
no shrapnel to it whatsoever must just
been a bag of aichi you know so when it
blew it actually blew in a gigantic ball
of flame and it partially cauterized my
arteries that were exposed and probably
actually saved my life at the same time
that amputated both of my legs in my arm
because I didn't lose consciousness and
he wasn't forced to do tourniquets and
all kinds of other stuff to try to save
me so you know whatever time I spent on
the ground then dust off helicopter in
about a 12 minute ride to the 95th of AK
and that's kind of the way that one
worked he didn't even put tourniquets on
you didn't have so you lost both legs
you lost your army didn't put
tourniquets on anything right that's
great is it burned shut Wow yeah and you
we burned anywhere else on your body
some yeah you know done my chest and
under this arm because most of the blast
came up the left hand side that's what
saved my right arm I guess we did you
where were you wearing a flak jacket no
did you how often were you guys wearing
flak jackets when you were on the track
and rolling but just out walking around
generally didn't you know you wouldn't
even you'd roll up your pant legs
because it was so hot you just wear a
t-shirt and carry your weapon so 12
minute flight and weird where'd they
take you the 95th back in Danang new
back hospital and were you still
conscious at this point no I lost
consciousness on the flight because they
knew I went into shock because it felt
like I was going to freeze to death as
soon as the chopper lifted off and then
I remember maybe a little bit of
consciousness when I first got to the
95th of AK don't know exactly what they
did there but there was a real slow
night so it wasn't like
a lot of casualties and they didn't have
to triage you never know how that might
work out either if they have to pick and
choose who they're gonna work on so they
just took me right in and you know got
me right up on the table to begin with
and went to work did you know did you
know
while you were cautious that you lost
your legs in your arm the only thing I
remember is when I was laying on my back
out in the field after the explosion was
I reached down with my good arm and I
could touch this stump is long enough
that if I'm laying on my back I can
probably touch it but not all the way to
the end so I felt like I still had this
leg I couldn't reach the other side I
didn't know how badly damaged all of
this was didn't know that till actually
got to Japan quite some time after you
know the evac Hospital in a bunch of
surgeries in Japan so when they would
you so when you lose consciousness they
put you in a medically induced coma they
didn't do that when I was at the 95th
back in Danang but they did it shortly
after I got to the 106 General in
Yokohama Japan and I was unconscious
from the 14th of January of 69 to the
15th of February of 69 31 days 31 days
that's a medically induced coma and then
you wake up and you're in Japan mm-hm
and what what is what kind of a shock
was that when you woke up well I mean I
really didn't know for sure exactly
where I was when I woke up but you know
I mean it doesn't take you too long to
figure out because the nurses are all
coming around and they would actually
straight up ask you do you know where
you are you know so if you didn't they
tell you and you know that was more for
me to spend five weeks that was highly
unusual normally all you did was come
through the 106 or at Camp Zama in Japan
for the army and they'd stabilized make
sure you were going to be strong enough
to make the trip back across the Pacific
to get get to back to the States and I
think they just once they got started
with me and on any surgeries I think
somebody just made a decision let's just
do all of them right here let's not
worry about waiting while we've got him
in the position that we have
let's just keep him there and go in and
out of surgery so I mean I'm actually
probably pretty fortunate that they did
and then the you know like a week after
I came out of the coma they tried to
feed you regular food but I'll guarantee
you that when you haven't eaten for five
weeks nothing looks real good it doesn't
taste very good either so but I did
regain enough strength to make the trip
back across the Pacific went to landed
in California at Travis Air Force Base
in California and spent the night and
then went on to Fitzsimmons General
Hospital in Aurora Colorado
that's right did the rest of my rehab
for another nine months so when you when
you figure out that you know you lost
both your legs you lost your arm what
what are you thinking at this point I
mean there's a lot of stuff when I when
I got back to the states I actually got
sick whether an airborne thing or
whatever it was and I mean I was stood
the point where not only could I not eat
old food but I couldn't even really
drink
hardly any liquid it wouldn't stay down
either so they kind of estimate I went
from 220 pounds before the explosion to
about 150 after the explosion and then
from the time they put me on the plane
in Japan and sent me back to the states
they figure I probably weighed about 135
pounds and then after I got sick at
Fitzsimmons until like you know actually
started being able to eat again I
weighed about 95 or 98 pounds so I think
did they share some photos with you I
did I yeah yeah sauce yeah and that that
one is kind of a scary I mean it's kind
of a ouch wits like looking photograph
like this is the way I described it
right yeah and and when you were going
through that are you thinking I mean is
it is it that you can't hold your food
down is it that your your don't have an
appetite I think it was probably a
combination of a lot of things but they
think I had some sort of a virus or
something that you know because I'd
really only been back to the States for
30 days and
almost a two-year period of time
something that I picked up summer could
have even been in the hospital in Japan
because I mean I ate food for a week in
Japan before I got on the flight back to
the States and when I got back to
Fitzsimmons I was just sick I mean I
couldn't horrible sick enough to lose
like 40 more pounds that's that's that's
crazy now did you get like the phantom
pain and your limbs and stuff for the
first five years it's really pretty bad
I mean it because it's like you still
feel like you have those limbs like you
feel like you need to scratch behind
your knee or scratch you know your hand
is itching that type of thing it's
almost like you're balled up in a fist
where your fingernails are pushed into
your hand type of thing and little by
little I think as those nerve endings
recede from the surgery and the
amputations a lot of that relaxes and
changes I don't get that at all anymore
but I mean it's been 50 years now so so
when you get to the Fitzsimmons Army
Medical Center to start your rehab I
mean at this point then it must have
been not too many guys that were in
worse shape than you are
at 90 pounds and sick and missing three
limbs I mean you must have been in
comparatively and the reason I say that
is because you know with the modern
advances with combat trauma and how
quickly we can medevac guys off the
battlefield and we get guys that are in
horrible suffering horrible wounds but
they're able to survive because the
medical advancements that we have but
for you it was like a miracle through
the the type of blast I mean because if
that would have been any other type of
blast the chances of you being alive are
very slim so when you got there
and what were the other guys thinking I
mean there was two other triple amputees
that were already at Fitzsimmons at the
time the the orthopedic wards were full
of single leg and double leg amputations
because I mean that's exactly what took
place in Vietnam all the time
not much different than Iraq and
Afghanistan or watch a lot of young guys
come back with multiple amputations
so I mean I think you you cared for one
another is where you got your support I
mean the hospital staff did everything
they possibly could they were incredible
doctors nurses you know aids whatever it
was but actually another triple amputee
was more beneficial to my survival
someone who'd been there for two months
three months or four months before I got
hurt you know and then you could at
least you could emulate and say you know
look if this guy can make it I can make
it I'm not sure what I'm gonna do with
the rest of my life but I think I'm
gonna be okay I'm gonna be alive and
then how long how long was that rehabbed
at Fitzsimmons that was nine months
total because I got discharged from the
military on the 22nd of November 1969
and that's occupational therapy working
with a prosthetic arm making sure that
you can use it and function with it I
had prosthetic legs walked in the
parallel bars but but not a it's not
anything you're going to use the rest of
your life and even if you fast forward
today's modern limbs with computers in
them and everything else it still
wouldn't work for a triple amputee and
in my condition and you wouldn't be able
to function the same way that I do today
to be able to get out and go and do
things and be aggressive if you had to
worry about trying to put those things
on deal with them all day long
worried about falling somewhere not
being able to get back up so I mean it
was a real easy decision for me in like
October early November 69 that will just
put those in a trunk someplace and have
great memories about walking in the
parallel bars so you are done with rehab
in nine months well really once you heal
and if you're not going to do anything
further with prosthetic legs and they
need a bed because they're still killing
and injuring a lot of people in Vietnam
in November in 1969 you you know you got
to move on something's got to happen so
1969 this is this is at the height of of
like anti-war protests and
Woodstock was in Woodstock was in August
of 1969 are you paying attention to that
is that entering your world at all or
we're watching it on the ward in the day
room and probably just getting a
tremendous amount of enjoyment out of it
because we're all sitting around we're
all Vietnam combat soldiers you know on
the ward so you know I think some people
actually talk but maybe we should go to
Woodstock
I don't think anybody did though Edie
but did you feel like like I know that
our treatment from the wars from the
wars that we've been in in the last
couple decades you know we've had great
treatment from for the most part we've
had incredibly incredible treatment from
not just from well from from people from
normal citizens you know that it's thank
you for your service it's thank you for
what you did regardless of whatever
their political beliefs are as well it's
like most people say hey we know that
you were doing your job and and that's
thank you did you feel that or did you
feel did you feel like it was did you
get the negative feedback that we often
hear about from Vietnam vets I never got
any of the negative personally I know a
lot of people who did and most of that
was people who came back uninjured who
got off of that same transport at Travis
Air Force Base or or up at Fort Lewis
Washington moved to a civilian aircraft
most of them would change out of their
military clothing in the civilian
clothing so that they couldn't be
recognized or wouldn't be readily
identified as being returning from
Vietnam the only thing that I ever
really experienced and I didn't know
this until after I got the Fitzsimmons
was Lowry Air Force Base used to be
right in downtown Denver and that's
normally where the transport would have
brought me would have been to Lowry but
because they reven protesters outside
the gate at Lowry Air Force Base they
landed in an old world war ii feel
called buckley field outside of Denver
and the protesters never knew where that
was at so then they load you on that on
the hospital bus and take you right to
the hospital
luckily the protesters weren't smart
enough to figure that out so you get
done with this you get discharged from
the army that's it
and now we go home and now and now
what's your what's your plan now
didn't have the faintest idea wish I
could tell you I'd really thought that
went out in a big way but I mean I think
you're you're kind of still in a form of
survival mode at that point you know
what I mean each each new experience I
mean getting in and out of the shower
getting on and off of a commode feeding
yourself putting clothes on wondering if
you're going to be able to drive again
are the things that are paramount in
your mind at that point because you know
what it takes to do stuff out there in
the world and I mean I would lie would
go to physical therapy I'd go to
occupational therapy I'd come back to
the ward and I'd be thinking about
things and my my Catholic upbringing in
in Minnesota and the Bible and and
things that take place I'm waiting for
something outside my hospital board
window like a burning bush or a bolt of
lightning and there's going to be a
revelation Jim Searcy this is what
you're gonna do for the rest of your
life it never happened it didn't come so
you know now I'm still praying but I'm
actually getting angry with God at this
point because I'm not getting any
answers and and maybe he's answering
things but I'm not smart enough to
recognize that I don't know but I think
what i actually did at that point which
i think is my my survival and what
allowed me to move forward with my life
was i surrendered I just said I said to
God here's the deal your job is to take
care of a vision or things that you have
in store for me for the rest of my life
my job is to do occupational therapy and
physical therapy and maybe as new guys
come in my job is to help inspire them
to realize that they're still going to
be a life beyond the injuries you've
sustained and I mean it's not like you
did that one day and the next day it was
perfect you know it was still a process
every day you'd have to kind of go
that little bit of surrender all the
time until you finally just came to the
conclusion that if you just relax do
what you're supposed to do everything
else is going to be okay
and it truly turned out that way so that
when you were going to occupational
therapy art is that when you're are you
still it at Fitzsimmons when you're
talking about that right and so now
you're helping people out you get this
kind of point in your life where you say
okay I'm gonna do my part and I'm gonna
let God handle his part I'm not gonna
worry about what he's gonna do with me
I'm gonna do what I'm supposed to do
right now you do that for nine months
when you get done it Fitzsimmons where
do you go I went back home to Rochester
Minnesota in state at my parents house
and I remember specifically with the the
chief of physical medicine said to my
mom when they were there said now
whatever you do when you get him home I
don't want you to wait on him all the
time because that's the worst thing you
can possibly do and you know they're
explaining that to your mother
and you're 21 years old and she knows
this guy's full of shit because I'm
gonna go home and just baby him like he
was two years old so I sat on the couch
for I mean not every day but on the
couch and I tell her to bring me the
remote and change the channel and get me
a Pepsi and do all that kind of stuff
and find me about 30 days into it I said
something to her one day and she said
why don't you get off your sorry ass and
get it yourself
and I said mom I just can't believe it
took you 30 days to give me that
response you melt it as long as you feel
it I said well I I I don't know if you
knew it mom but I overheard the chief of
Physical Medicine tell you that so I had
to use it so so then once so you're
living at home and what did that what
did that look like it's kind of a scary
experience because you're going back to
an able-bodied world even though the
male clinic's there in Rochester
Minnesota they're still streets don't
have curb cuts buildings are not level 2
the grow
and every building doesn't have an
elevator to get you to the second floor
Americas with Disability Act didn't come
into play until the late 70s or early
80s so I mean it wasn't like anybody had
to do anything to accommodate disabled
people there were not a lot of disabled
people on the street out in public
either working or going to school or
anything else they had there was a
system off to the side I think for
disabled people but I think Vietnam
veterans came back and were vocal and
pushy and just decided we weren't
willing to accept that as being the
standard and that's not what I want to
do for the rest of my life so primarily
I came back on a shorter junior college
and then at least when you're in school
there's that groups at school so he had
that sharing again I mean if I had
difficulty getting from one location to
another I could hollering somebody
they'd give me a push to my next class
or carry books and I'd push whatever so
I mean little by little you realized you
got to swallow a little bit of pride you
may need that help at times if you're
going to get back into civilian life if
you're going to be part of it and if you
want to join the human race that's what
you're going to have to do is accept
some help and some guidance along the
way so that's what I did and little by
little that just gets better every day
and every week in every year's
seastar you see what did you start
studying in school well I wanted to be a
CPA until I actually got to all those
big long ledger shoots and they said oh
my god really
I don't want to do this for the rest of
my life so just I just changed the
general business general business and
then you graduate from Junior College
graduated from junior college went to
what's now called the University of
Central Florida was called ftu at the
time continued towards the business
degree but did not finish and get a
degree but I finished about halfway
through my senior year and then and then
one day I went to work and what you go
to work doing well I've been a real
Dejan for forty years in Florida and
then I'm also a real estate investor and
I have a small roofing company so
straight from school you you must have
started to delve into real estate before
he decided you were gonna leave school I
had actually the guy I knew the guy real
welded on the real estate company and he
had asked me because they had a van slot
up you know people with wheelchairs use
we would carry his real estate signs out
the bigger ones and smaller ones and I
would I would drive and he would put up
the signs he was fairly new in the
business too so I think that just sort
of got me excited about what he was
doing and I would he would say you need
to go get your real estate license I
said yeah when was the last time you
bought a house from a guy in a
wheelchair missing two legs in an arm
because I don't worry about it they'll
never even notice I mean that's just the
kind of guy he was it sounds like he was
right he was absolutely
it doesn't take arms and a leg to
explain to people that this thing has
the bathroom central air and heat three
bedrooms and all that kind of stuff
usually most people are pretty
intelligent lesser blind and they can't
see it they can pretty well figure out
what it is
my pointing those things out doesn't
make them want to buy it what it is and
where it is is usually why they buy it
and that was is that it is that what you
ended up doing for your whole career
said you've been doing it for four or
you did it for 40 years or I got my real
estate license in 1978 and then courses
is part of selling things deals come
along that are worth owning
so I would buy him kept them for rental
property and still have all those today
nice moves I got to ask you this because
you know a lot of a lot of vets listen
to this what did you see in terms of
alcohol and drugs especially when you're
in rehab when you're coming out of rehab
what did you see what was your attitude
how did you avoid going down the path of
where people end up you know either
addicted to alcohol or addicted to drugs
you know and that's a kind of a good
question because there was a lot of that
there were a lot of guys especially
alcohol cuz you could just go off the
base and and go someplace in the evening
the drugs I think they were a little
less likely to give you more than you
actually needed during the Vietnam era
that was my experience and my father was
an alcoholic so I'm sure probably in the
back of my mind the use of it or abusive
it was probably something I was
conscious of all the time
but that never really looked like that
was a great alternative path I mean I
thought that was fairly easy to
recognize that that wasn't good and and
I and I'm not critical of anyone that
shows that because everybody's psyche
and the way they're handling things at
that time the difficulties are going
through or just being out in public
missing two legs and arm maybe you need
to be high to do that I never felt that
way I didn't feel like I needed to
explain anything to anybody had to put
on any particular performance or airs to
make people to accept me if you didn't
accept me I'm okay with that too you
know what I mean that was fine because
I'm just gonna do what I need to do for
my survival and for me to move forward
and I had a lot of support from family
and friends that allowed me to be that
way man I wish I could spread that word
to basically everyone you know not to
worry about what other people are think
deal what you're supposed to do at what
point did you at what point did you did
you link up with the with the DAV well
the DAV initially gave me what they call
a complimentary membership all Vietnam
era veterans that were injured out that
that was in 1970 and then I moved from
Minnesota to Florida in March in 1971
and my wife at the time said what are
you going to do about that membership in
the DAV and I said you know I really
hadn't given it much thought I was busy
with with the job that I had moved there
for and
I know she looked it up I think when
time said well there's a chapter in
Sanford so I actually started going
welcome me with open arms it was a nice
friendly group of people and I mean it
was a great great great relationship
with them and I needed that so maybe she
was even smarter than I was to recognize
that it's nice to be able to go back and
associate with other disabled veterans
because you're actually there to lift
that person up and bring them along and
they're there to do the same thing for
you if you can be an inspiration great
not maybe you can be inspired by
somebody that's there so that's my
initial strong involvement on the local
chapter level was in Sanford Florida
Seminole chapter 30 and then just stayed
involved constantly I mean you know
we're 50 years this year DAV is going to
celebrate the 100th anniversary I'm
going to celebrate my 50th anniversary
being a member of the DAV now you
mentioned that in that whole thing that
you got married at some point where year
was that I got married in February in
1972 a young lady that I met in the
community of Denver Colorado so that was
that was while you were at Fitzsimmons
no I was home okay
met her when I was at Fitzsimmons god I
married back in Rochester Minnesota got
it and then did you Edie you ended up
having kids with her two children two
two boys we're now 44 or 45 and 43 years
old
that's awesome and then you moved up
through the ranks of the DAV correct
well I did a lot of stuff in the local
chapter then I got involved on the
department level which is what we call
our state organizations became an
officer in the state went through all
the chairs became you know a department
commander and then obviously people who
had been in the national organization
before recognize it maybe I could be a
national officer asked me if I would
consider doing that so in 1999 I
initially got elected to what we call
the fourth junior vice commander the
beginning
of your working your way up to be a
national commander so now we're talking
1999 where were you on on September 11th
2001 I was home in Apopka and what did
that when you saw that I mean obviously
you must have heard the war drums like
everybody else what were what were you
thinking I mean almost unbelievable to
begin with that that could ever happen
here on American soil and then I don't
know where I was to originally but then
my wife had hollered to me and in the
plane was hit the second building by the
time I got in front of the television
and I mean we knew it was real I mean
it's it's a shock to think that anything
like that can happen in two buildings
full of people just unbelievable
now did you immediately I mean we were
in Afghanistan by October were you
thinking to yourself where there's war
there's gonna be wounded and the DAV and
and your you know you talked about how
much it helped you to meet somebody that
was a triple amputee two months before
you three months before you they didn't
even have much experience with it but it
was enough to make you say okay if they
can make it I can make it did you think
to yourself here we go again I don't
know whether I ever came to that
conclusion that early on but as you know
it didn't take long before we started
getting wounded back and as long as I
was a National officer I always asked if
I could go up to DC and spend a day or
two so I could go through Walter Reed
and spend time visiting young men and
women coming back from Iraq and
Afghanistan so I I look forward to
having that opportunity to do that and
one of the guys I mean this is
fast-forwarding some but a young man
came back at injured in September of
2004 and he was also a triple amputee
lost both legs in an arm and you because
of the HIPPA laws you had to go through
and get permission to visit people in
the hospital well he had originally been
on our list and then each scratched
the DAV off of that because they were
kind of getting tired of politicians
just coming and doing photo ops was
seriously injured vets so he kind of
thought that's what it was while we were
visiting another young guy that was a
single leg amputee on the on the
physical therapy ward and he was in a
bed maybe fifteen feet away so he called
the officer over that was with us and
said who the hell's that guy said well
that's the guy was gonna come to visit
she goes oh hell I'll see him you know
because we were we were one in the same
so my wife was with me on that trip as
well too so we went over to the bed when
we finished with this first young man
and talked to him a little bit and it's
not a matter that you're you're gonna be
doing any great wonderful pep talk it's
kind of just more a matter of explaining
I'm just exactly like you are I've been
in that bed it was back in in you know
1969 I've been through a lot of
difficulties but you're gonna be okay
you're alive his mother and his fiancee
we're standing at the end of the bed and
my wife was talking to them and I truly
believe that she was probably more
inspirational and more informative to
them than I ever was with him in that
one initial meeting he'd after we'd have
to see each other multiple times as he
started to grow a little bit and get out
of bed and get into a wheelchair where
he where he pretty well understands it
is gonna be okay it is gonna be better
man today which is how many years ago is
that 25 or something maybe more than
that he's college-educated got a wife
two children hugely successful and you
know I could probably say well part of
that was my inspiration but I think part
of that was the grit he was raised with
the kid from Michigan as well too he was
probably going to be okay no matter what
happened but you know to see him do that
makes me feel extremely good that the
younger generation is picking up on that
and they're moving forward and getting
along with their lives as well too ya
know that's yeah that's that's
unbelievable I mean obviously
you might not feel like you may feel
like you would have done it anyways but
you know anything that you do in life
when you see that someone else has done
it and and you know it's possible I mean
that's so much of the battle right there
it's just knowing that something can be
done and for someone to look at you and
see that you got kids and you got wife
and you got business and you got damn
apartment complexes and whatnot
and and you carry you carry on for
someone that's well however old 19 20 23
years old and say okay I've been putting
this rough spot but I can but I can do
this he did it if he did it I can do it
that's a man that's that's that's worth
its weight in gold is there anything
that that we can do to help out the the
DAV anything that that just people at a
listen to this show that that recognize
the the benefits that that the DAV
provides what's the best thing for
people to do to support it well I mean I
think there's a lot of different things
in their local community there's
opportunities at local chapters there's
a department level donations to our
national organization that allow us to
continue to do great things every single
day I think the numbers were talking
about right now is we provide service to
over a million veterans every single
year and it may not be the same service
of service work when the claims
representation it might be
transportation to and from VA medical
centers for guys that don't have a way
to get there for their doctor's
appointments they might we might be
volunteers and hospitals we can use help
in all those areas from the American
public so the the the website is DAV org
they're actually quite high speed on
their social media they have Twitter
which is at DAV HQ they have Instagram
which is also at DAV HQ and then they
have Facebook which is just at
DAV and anyone can get on there they
have pretty good um you know it's pretty
pretty simple to figure out how you can
help how you can volunteer how you can
do donate to that to that awesome cause
and you know I started off this podcast
with a quote from you when you were
talking about how lucky you were and and
even just before we before we pressed
record today
you were you were explaining you were
just saying to me you know you've had
this life that you wouldn't trade any
part of it and I think anybody that's
that's listening to you seeing you talk
hear you talk to have that attitude and
maintain that attitude that is that is
the most powerful thing that a person
can have for you to be in the situation
that you were in ninety pounds lost both
your legs lost your arm and to get up
and move forward I mean that that
mentality is it's it's it's unbelievable
it's it's it's miraculous and it's and
it's it's inspirational when you look
back now do you ever feel do you feel
like this was the way it was meant to be
well I think because of my faith in God
I believe that nothing happens to you
that that he doesn't think you can
handle that's the way I prayed my entire
life is it's not I don't pray so that I
wake up tomorrow morning I've got two
legs and an arm
I pray that I have the same opportunity
tomorrow that I had today or maybe maybe
something more I can do tomorrow not so
much but I'm asking for something so I
think really truly the best thing that I
can say is my injury is from the neck
down but my ability to continue on is
from the neck up it's it's the way you
think and what you want to do is again
from the neck up if somebody said well
how in the world can you have our
roofing company well that's real easy I
don't get on the roof you mean that
doesn't look like that'd be a whole lot
of fun it's easier for me to get
customers do the estimates and do the
money part of it and and hire people
that do the work so but I've never
looked at that and said well you can't
do that if you're missing two legs in an
arm sure you can you can do anything if
you're missing two legs in an arm
anybody out there are DAV members or
anybody that sustained any form of an
injury that wants to give up I'm just
here to tell you you don't need to give
up don't ever give up there's a
challenge out there just accept the
challenge and move forward well I don't
think I have anything else to say
after that you got anything else that's
the floor is yours I just want to thank
you again I know we did at the beginning
of the podcast but thank you for the
opportunity for allowing DAV and me to
come as our representative to be on the
program with you I hope we got millions
of people out there that heard the
podcaster will hear it in the future and
that they'll remember that the DA bee is
if they're a veteran it's there for them
and their family independence if they're
a member of the American public that
would just like to reach out and do
something to help their fellow disabled
veterans you can get old a DA bo RG just
like you mentioned before we would
welcome the opportunity that you would
come to us and offer to help
well I'm sure that folks will definitely
do that and I know you're thanking me
for for having you out here but this is
it's absolute honor for me to be able to
sit here and talk with you and thank you
for coming on the show and thanks for
sharing your experiences and more
important thank you for your service for
your sacrifice and not just what you did
you know in Vietnam but for what you've
done with the DAV and what you've done
to help you know my generation of
warriors who have suffered greatly and
who are able to look at you as a mentor
and as an inspiration so that they can
do
actly what you said which has never give
up and keep moving forward so with that
thank you for coming on the show and
thank you for everything thank you jack
I appreciate it
and with that mr. serge Lee has left the
building
yep how does that man not change your
attitude about just about everything
that you do
he's that day-to-day basis yeah oh yeah
big time and he said something that kind
of is this was real small but I was like
it's different when you're talking about
um how or when he was talking about how
he didn't drink and do that and his
dad's alcoholic so that's like that's
not just oh yeah I just didn't but the
way he said it was this he was like I
knew that that wasn't a path I was gonna
go go down right but then he said and I
want to kind of let I'm paraphrasing
obviously I want to let everyone know
that you don't you don't have to give up
or something he said he didn't say don't
give up like a big thing it's like you
know he said you don't need to give up
there I'm kind of thing because it went
in my mind anyway it seemed like like
giving up seems like such a viable
option you know yeah for sure and they
say oh no you don't need to do that yeah
we don't need to do that let kind of
like know you can actually do this other
thing kind of thing like he made it
sound so casual wit almost like hey that
it it's almost like he reversed it all
the way back down to the bare
decision-making of it you know rather
than like all this hard battle or
whatever it's hard about a hundred
percent but that's not what he was
focusing on the way he said it that's
what it sounded like oh man that's kind
of a interesting sort of way to present
it yeah you don't know you give up
sometimes we stop record too because he
just told a really cool story about the
fact that his first sergeant was telling
him hey if you stay in you get a ten
thousand dollar reenlistment bonus and a
brand-new Corvette which you can order
here will get delivered to your house
for 50 500 bucks
and you know what he said hey hey listen
First Sergeant there's people here
trying to kill me if I'm good so how
about me yeah I'll buy my own Corvette
when I get home so you know that's when
you when you hear a guy like him you
just realize that there's so much more
that we are capable of overcoming and
and he's saying he's lucky and it's just
if he's lucky to be here we're all lucky
to be here
mm-hmm we and what we need to do is make
sure we take advantage of the
opportunities that we have getting our
attitude straight being on the path
stayin on the path so echo Charles
speaking of the path yes what can we do
well as we always talk about first
jiu-jitsu we can do to Jitsu we're at
Victory MMA in the main what we call
this corridor we call it a corridor
we're in the kind of lounge this is the
lounge area
oddly enough I have to admit that I have
a lounge area in my gym right instead of
having more squat racks just in case you
get alone yeah I got a lounge area yes
is the echo Charles lounge area I prefer
to call it the recovery area okay so
he's got nice couches unless we're here
yeah and yes so this is where we can do
jujitsu kudos more mat space here by the
way side note yeah more jujitsu we got a
lot of jujitsu going on here yes you can
pretty much do jujitsu
a lot here yes sir you can you can get
you notice you can get here origin geese
yeah you can come here to victory MMA in
San Diego and get an origin geek right
here and if that's a far trip for you
guess what you can go to origin main
comm you can get an origin key yep you
can get an origin rash guard you can get
origin genes and guess what you can get
well I can easily guess you can get
boots because you guys who just got
their gloves you get your origin boots
yes sir I did
how sweeter that
extra sweet it's it's kind of crazy
right when you look at those boots and
you think we just started that process
and I'm throwing that boy out there I'm
taking like I'm filling my name and
there you did not make I did not for me
no but what we got a maid yeah like an
American people got a maid yeah he the
crew the folks up there
it's awesome so yes origin main comm you
can get all kinds of clothing t-shirts
hoodies all that and supplements
important supplements critical
supplements to stay in the game and if
you don't think they're critical try not
taking them that's not a good point
where for a krill oil combo my
suggestion recommendation strong
represent recommendation UH one more
thing we've got right now so we have
discipline in a powder form and it's
sort of like a pre mission cognitive and
physical enhancement so we just came out
with a new flavor the new flavor is
called Jaco Palmer it's 50% iced tea
50% lemonade and it's really really
really good it's in fact it's all I'm
drinking right now unless I'm having a
discipline going to cancer
wait so the the one you have the the
jungle Palmer that's the powder one it's
not this one go it's discipline yes and
discipline go in a can Jaco Palmer is
coming okay we're gonna cover all the
bases we also got dak savage well what
is that another Kota Myers Dakota Myers
custom what no no no wait better a
signature signature signature from
Dakota what flavor the flavor is called
cherry vanilla which if you know
anything about flavors that's basically
a dr. pepper
what okay so it's sodac savage is the
name of the flavor of discipline from
Dakota Meyer that tastes like Dr Pepper
Dakota Meyer signature signature flavor
signature flavor so anyways that was
coming out so
and we also got Molk for your protein or
you can call it protein or you can just
call it dessert dessert I do prefer to
call it dessert because that's basically
what it tastes like do would you ever
and and this thought flashed in my head
last night and almost almost not gonna
admit it but I'm gonna tell you cuz you
know I've known you for a long time so I
trust you so I had a little thing of
leftover rocky road ice cream my son's
birthday a while back and so my why not
why not give him a bunch of you know
sugar well there was a lot left we
didn't eat that much but so I busted it
out left it on the counter kind of ate
some and sort of forgot about it it
might whatever it melted oh but it's in
the woody core I don't know if it's a
plane
the bigger one but your than half kept
coming in hot
so I'm like all right whatever have a
milkshake in this rocky road ice cream
milkshake out of the container by the
way it's night time nobody so
but I'm pounding Martian to these little
marshmallows in their little nuts what's
in rocky would like almonds or no walnut
yeah we're nuts some kind of nuts
yeah nuts yeah and marshmallows anyway
it was not bad it was good
did you put milk in there but I'm
thinking no I didn't see I could have
oil but it was sort of what a difference
but what if you put marshmallows and
nuts in milk you could do that it'd kind
of be the same thing I don't like
marshmallows by the way yeah I don't
either
I don't like marshmallows I don't like
any marshmallows except let's face it
whatever those kinds of marshmallows are
that are in Lucky Charms
oh yeah those when I was a kid I was I
was all about those lucky charms and the
crazy thing is it was just normal
you just Saturday morning this is a
thing he used to think cartoons Saturday
morning that's what that's what kids did
yeah those Lucky Charms marshmallows
though they're kind of odd because like
I mean I guess a if you dig on my day
but those the dehydrated ones when you
eat them you get that you know that like
nails against the chalkboard filling
those not hydrated much you don't even
try I probably haven't had any of that
since I was in Iraq
that's right the last time I had some
Lucky Charms like there was some box in
the whatever yeah I don't know man I was
like cinnamon toast crunch
it's in Mentos crunch back in there I
think that was like the weakness theory
another one oh you know this these are
bad but it's I think we might have just
gotten off track cuz we're talking about
Lucky Charms and cinnamon crumb oh yeah
what are we even talking about Mulk
additional protein tastes delicious and
for kids instead of feeding your kids
cereal or rocky road ice cream give it
if you would have told your son hey
that's it's your birthday here's a
strawberry milkshake yeah and you gave
him strawberry milk you'd have been
totally pumped and healthy and stronger
yeah when you didn't do that don't
forget about soccer whitey as well
mm-hmm so they're checking out orange in
Maine calm calm yes also Chuck what
store it's called jockle store and this
is where you can get and I know we are
saying this again if you like hey
everyone knows but here's the thing
not everyone knows so anyway Jacques was
a store it's called jhaqo store
chocolate store calm is where you can
get t-shirts discipline equals freedom
if you want to represent while you're on
the pair's a new t-shirt by the way yes
disability equals freedom it's a I call
it I don't even know what I call it def
discipline equals freedom because it has
an X you know the x over the d that
that's layers right there it is I'm not
gonna disclose what the X is for some
people know already actually on Twitter
someone who's like hey I see you did
that and he explained what it was I who
this guy knows unless yes
new shirt just went equals freedoms on
their chocolate or hoodies on their yup
truckers hats flex fit hats
beanie is on the way I sweat like we
were out of beanies for a while you want
to just say that like that's a big
surprise that we ran out of stuff
because you don't do a good job of
explaining you how important it so it's
my know what we are doing for we people
put me up put hit me up on social media
say oh there's an earlier there's eight
things I want to get in the store and
there's none of them they're like oh
that's my fault no no I tagged you and
say all iPhone it is my fault
no so we collectively dude a lot better
and the beanies are on their way there
was there was a thing there was a little
curve little
little that we had to kind of maneuver
and nonetheless we getting it sorted out
okay less they will be available jaw
closed or calm good place to get also
subscribe to the podcasts if you haven't
already
echo thinks that you may not have I have
faith in you that you subscribe to the
podcast yes don't forget about the
warrior kid podcast also also subscribe
to that one is working on some new ones
yeah we are for a while yeah don't
forget to get some warrior kid soap from
Irish Oaks ranch calm yes young Aiden
has sold sold his 1000th bar of soap
that's entrepreneurship men yeah and ego
milk just as impressive as or maybe even
more impressive of the fact that we has
his own business when I was 13 because
that's when he started when he was 13
right or 12 12 yeah so when I was that
yeah and I was doing 11 yeah well not
your business buttons
what about buttons I used to sell
buttons like nothing not for your shirt
but you know the bow appearances but for
Pedro we had yeah we had the old school
well my mom did the little button maker
yeah you buy all the little Ross
supplies from the echo fans are going
nuts right now cuz you're saying BOTS
and over and over anyway so I you say we
draw you know you'd make the design
designs for what the button but the
button Oh make this anyway and you clamp
it and he didn't you make the but you
know and people would make customer and
I'd sell them for like 75 cents or
something there that they cost a dollar
each but it's all great no it's like a
dollar for the whole make it ROM is here
you you mean no nonetheless I was like
yeah that's cool and it is cool to have
a little business more but Aidan's
making the sprout come let's face it man
if someone goes without their budgets I
could cares but so that's like okay you
can't just make so you know you got to
know how to do that stuff and then he's
making so from actual goat's milk that
he raises yeah so it's a he's way
advanced man
Irish Oaks ranch doc
stay clean yes sir also we have a
youtube channel trying to see what
everybody looks like if you care I dig
it if you don't but nonetheless we want
to see the video version of this podcast
that's where you go Josh even has a good
voice yeah doesn't he yeah yeah like he
that's a powerful voice yeah yeah you
can tell he was like a brick he said he
was what 220 yeah when I was in 1960
whatever 1969 guys weren't as big as
they are now yeah but you can tell you
big shake is like sure
like Dean Lister hands yeah
psychological god that's a YouTube
channel you know it looks like you know
and if you wanna see echoes enhanced
videos where he starting to work with CG
hideout so now I think they're gonna be
enhanced and it's just gonna get stupid
yeah everything is going on that no one
can imagine yeah those four days I don't
like CGI and ident generally don't like
any movies with a lot of explosions in
them and that is like your thing so
there's gonna if you it's gonna get to a
certain point where we're no longer like
gonna be able to work things out yeah
but hey look I think I'm gonna make it
work I think so okay put it this way I
won't do all explosions in CGI okay
maybe I don't know let's just say that
that's not the concrete plant yeah we
got psychological warfare as well which
is an album with tracks where you can
get a little oh did you say hitter you
know our situation is good I enjoyed it
maybe let me do it the whole thing just
a little excerpts that you know have
been put out but yet they influenced me
in him and I said it hit her you didn't
say more cater today you need that one
scoop and so if you need a little
psychological hitter to get you through
a moment of weakness you can check out
psychological warfare or if you need an
alarm clock for your iPhone or your
Android phone you can put psychological
warfare on there now and I will
personally wake you up in the morning
every morning don't get mad at me if you
are married to someone that's doing this
not my fault I do not take ownership I'm
running away
all right so yes also flipside canvas
speaking of Dakota Meyer dak savage he
has got a little company where he makes
will call it artistic haters the joke
already played out okay cool yeah check
it out flip side cameras calm to get
things graphic designs to hang up in
your house so that you can stay on the
path also I've written a bunch of books
the next one that's coming out is called
leadership strategy and tactics and it
is available for pre-order right now it
is a field manual of how to lead
pragmatically how to lead actual
instructions an actual field manual on
how to lead also have way the warrior
kid one two and three get those books
for every kid you know and the library
and the school because every kid should
be reading those I hear that at least
once a day
mm-hmm someone tells me every kid should
get issued these books I agree why
because we all wish we had the way the
warrior kid books when we were kids we
didn't have him and we suffer the
consequences don't don't punish the
children of the world no get them the
books and also if you got a younger kid
get him Mikey and the dragons which by
the way somebody bought the flipside
canvas Mike gain the Dragons poster and
said that this was the this was the what
they read with their son before the Sun
went on deployment so it's like oh yeah
overcome your fears that doesn't that's
not only for kids Mikey and the Dragons
get that book read it and a disciplined
close freedom Field Manual how to get
after it the audio version is on iTunes
and mp3 things extreme ownership and the
dichotomy of leadership the first two
books I wrote with my brother lathe
babban these are all the leadership
principles that we talk about all the
time on this podcast for your business
and for your life check those out a
tional on front that is our leadership
consultancy
what we do is solve problems through
leadership if you need help with your
company go to echelon front comm we have
EF online if you need to get additional
training which you do you can't get
complacency with complacent with your
leadership attitude
so get EF online interactive online
training to keep you to keep you honed
to keep your leadership skills honed
check out EF online.com or if you've got
a big company there's another one this
is the reason we created it originally
is so that companies with 38,000
employees can get everyone in their
company aligned when it comes to
leadership
so check out EF online.com we have one
more muster left this year it is in
Sydney Australia we are not gonna go
back to Sydney Australia for a long time
so if you want to come check us out and
we're also not gonna go to Perth and
we're not gonna go to Brisbane and we're
not gonna go to anywhere else in
Australia so if you're like oh I'll just
wait until they come to my hometown in
Australia we're not even going to your
hometown in America if you're in America
it's not happening we're not a rock band
on tour we're not playing every club we
can't do it we don't have the time so if
you want to come to the muster in Sydney
Australia to December 4th and 5th go to
extreme ownership calm every muster
we've done has sold out so register
early we also have EF overwatch so if
you have a company and you want spec ops
or combat aviation leaders coming into
your company to help with your
leadership then go to EF overwatch comm
to connect and find one of those leaders
to come into your company and if you
have comments or questions or answers
for us you can find them on the
interwebs you can find us on the
interwebs we are on Twitter we on
Instagram and we are on Facebook key
for the disabled american veterans they
are at DAV HQ on instagram and on
twitter and then on facebook e they are
just at DAV and echo is at echo Charles
and I am at Joc a will Inc and once
again thanks to mr. Jim
sirs Lee for sharing his story with us
and I am it's such an honor for me to be
able to talk with such men and women who
have given so much and yet they continue
to give and to all the other veterans
out there to those that have served and
those that are serving and those that
are holding the line as we speak thanks
to each one of you for fighting for our
freedom and to our police and law
enforcement and firefighters and
paramedics and EMTs and dispatchers and
correctional officers and Border Patrol
and Secret Service and all the first
responders each of you work so hard and
give so much to keep us safe
here at home so thanks to all of you as
well for your service and to everyone
else out there you just heard another
example of what the human will is
capable of and even when facing the most
unimaginable challenges even when ripped
apart by a bomb the will to live and the
will to fight and the will to overcome
is unstoppable and what that what that
makes me wonder makes me wonder what are
we capable of what are we capable of if
we summoned the kind of will that Jim
serves Lee asks
are we doing everything right now that
we are capable of doing are we reaching
our potential how much more could we do
how much more could we do there's only
one way to find out and that is to step
up into the breach to put yourself out
there every day and do everything you
possibly can to get after it and until
next time this is echo and Jocko out